Hey, hows it going. It's time for a update
and you know what that means.
WAT DID WE FIND? TREASURE?
Say hi to Slippy everyone
Slippy bad ass confirmed
I have an important update I need to make I just realized I've forgotten something...
OH WAIT ITS RIGHT HERE
squirt me daddy
Here we go...
I'm going away.
lik if u cri ev3ryt1me
SQUIRT ME MORE
Likin' intensifys
A friend of mine is gonna take care of Slippy (RIP Slippy) while I'm gone.
I hope they do a good job cuz I really care about you Slippy (BULLSHIT)
I just wish you would stop shiting you know? (No)
Uh, I'm going away to Los Angeles (MARKIPLIER COLLAB?)
Just like I did last year
If you remember. HAVE YOU BEEN WATCHING THAT LONG???
*sighs*
I hate myself (We all do)
I'm not supposed to say
why I'm there
but I'm going at the exact same time
for the exact same amount,
just like I did last year
so if you have a brain (I don't) you'll figure out
that I'm doing 'Scare Pewdiepie' (Not sponsored) I don't know
why I'm not
supposed to say that. Just makes it...
everything complicated for no good
reason. But yeah I'll be away for 3
weeks. But I decided that I was going to
daily vlog during that time.
Last year
I had prepared videos in advance
and it was a fucking nightmare.
It's the worst time OH
OH IT'S CUMMING (lol)
Slippy is bad anus confirmed again
Oh shit it's a lot of shit happening
Ok alright. Yeah no
last year was
the worst point in my YouTube career
because I was so forced to make
videos while I was being away. So this
year I just decided to daily vlog.
Instead I'm gonna
daily vlog, I'm gonna DAILY VLOG, it's a huge
announcement I'M DAILY VLOGGING -- Slippy
do you understand
the consequences of what's happening? (No) Gonna daily vlog
It should be
a lot of fun, I'm really excited
I'm genuinely excited.
Cause I, uhh... You know how
people call their vlogs something special?
Like, "Vlogmas" or
or like the "Vlogly" and whatever
I'm gonna call it "BIRDABO". (BEST NAME 2016!!)
*Birdabo, I choose you!*
for absolutely no reason at all.
I just thought it was the dumbest name I could think of.
I think my videos have been pretty
inconsistent lately which, believe it or not, still kind of affects me
If a video's doing badly, I'm not too happy about it.
I think it would be nice for me to change the pace a little bit,
and do something different for a while
and I think you bros will enjoy it as well.
Last years vlogs were very VERY popular and successful
and a lot of people liked them *insert creepy mask meme*
so I think it could be a lot of fun to share that adventure with you guys
I will still do regular videos while I'm there as well,
but I think the main thing is going to be......   *wait for it*
THE DAILY VLOGGING
the BIRDABO
I'm gonna meet a lot of cool people while I'm in LA
I'm really excited, there's a lot of people flying in for the show.
I think a lot of Scare Pewdiepie
didn't really work, but I think a lot of it...
some episodes are really Really REALLY funny
and I think we're really focused in on what worked
and we're just gonna keep doing that.
Yeah, been kind of stressing out over me leaving for such a long time.
So, for me to be away it freaks you out a little bit       *eyes widen in Swedish*
But y'know DAILY VLOGGING
it should be fun!
BIRDABO, everyone!!!!
BIRDABO! Clap it up! *claps* It's gonna be very hype and very happy!
I'll be your hands! *laughs in Swedish* This looks awesome by the way
I just realized... "Hi, how's it goin'? This is Garble here.
Let me tell you about BIRDABO."
Oh, what am I doing?!?! This is so silly! This is not my hands!
Why would I do..??
Thank you for always supporting me when ever I do different stuff
Um, I'm really proud to have an audience that lets me explore and do different things
even though sometimes it doesn't work. Sometimes it does and um...
I really appreciate that you guys are here. *awwww*
The fact that you guys have been supporting me for years is incredible *i will always b h3r3 poods*
and just...I did not think I would still be where I am today a year ago
while doing the same thing
Honestly, I'm just happy that I'm still able to do this and I...
...from the bottom of my heart, thank you for supporting me NU THANK YOU
cause you make it happen by watching my videos.
So I really hope you will enjoy BIRDABO.
It's gonna be a fresh...New...EXPERIENCE
And, um, that's it from me for now! *kisses fist*
Stay awesome bros! *Brofist*
*fade to black*
(Welp, thanks for watching.)
(I should have been doing my Chem Lab homework but...here I am!)
(...So, how about that weather?)
(That's nice.)
(Well, I've got better things to do with my time...like listening to Hamilton.)
(Buh-Byeeeee!) *fade to black*
we love you pewds <3 :)